Lunettes,
casquette,
frisbee,
c'est la vidéo des vacances !
Salut les p'tits mentalos, de la Team Mentalo, c'est la dernière vidéo avant mes vacances.
Quoi ?! Mais qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?! Il arrête le Mental Vlog ?
Je n'arrête pas le Mental Vlog, au contraire !
Avant de vous dire exactement ce qu'il va se passer à partir de demain, je vais vous dire ce qu'il va se passer à partir de mon retour.
Je vais prendre le temps de revoir un peu la chaine, de mettre les mains dans le cambouis, comme on dit.
Puisque mon rythme de publication qui est quotidien,
ne me permet pas de prendre assez de temps ou assez de recul.
Donc je vais revoir l'habillage de la chaine, est-ce que je fais une intro ou pas,
est-ce que je ne pourrais pas produire un petit peu mieux,
est-ce que je ne peux écrire différemment...
J'ai vraiment envie d'améliorer encore plus la chaine, vis-à-vis de vous, vis-à-vis de moi aussi.
En fait, pour notre plaisir à tous.
Si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo numéro 100 sur 366,
d'ailleurs on me demande des fois pourquoi c'est sur 366,
c'est parce que c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an, et qu'il y a 366 jours,
et que j'ai commencé le premier janvier.
Donc si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo numéro 100, allez la voir car je fait une annonce dessus, sur le jour où l'on atteindra les 50 000 abonnés.
Je vous le répète comme ça un peu plus rapidement, mais quand on sera 50 000 abonnés sur la chaine,
je me mettrai à organiser un Mental Up.
Et qu'est-ce qu'un Mental Up ?!
Un Mental Up, c'est un petit peu comme un meet up, sauf que de manière informelle,
ce ne sera pas forcément sur une scène, je vais vous présenter les nouveautés que je suis en train d'écrire pour le nouveau spectacle.
C'est-à-dire que c'est plus qu'inédit, c'est de l'inédit, de l'inédit, de l'inédit !
Ce sera fait en mode informel. Je vous demanderai aussi vos avis:
ce que vous aimez, ce que vous n'aimez pas, ce qui vous a bluffé, ce qui ne vous a pas bluffé...
comme ça vous allez participer en quelque manière au test du beta test, du beta beta test
du nouveau spectacle.
Donc vous l'aurez compris à cette chemise ridicule, à partir de demain je pars en vacances.
En vacances quoi !
Je pars en vacances !
Qu'est-ce qu'il va se passer sur la chaine pendant les vacances ?
Toujours la même chose: une vidéo par jour à 17H la semaine, et à 11H les samedis et dimanches.
Sauf que l'on ne va pas suivre le calendrier habituel de la chaine.
Tout d'abord pendant les quelques prochains jours qui viennent, je vais vous apprendre à résoudre ceci.
A apprendre à résoudre ce Rubik's Cube en moins de 2 minutes et avec seulement 5 formules.
Ce sont les vidéos que j'avais préparé au cas où je sois malade dans la première partie de l'année,
et que j'avais décidé de mettre sinon, le jour où je voudrais prendre des vacances.
C'est le cas.
Ce sont également les premières vidéos que j'ai filmé au YouTube Space à Paris.
J'avais filmé ça, pour ce qui me suivent sur les réseaux sociaux.
Et c'est très très facile à faire un Rubik's Cube, comme vous pouvez d'ailleurs le constater.
Mais vous aussi bientôt vous allez faire ça.
Mais après cette série de vidéos, qu'est-ce qu'il va se passer ?
Parce que je ne serai pas encore rentré...
Durant tout le mois d'aout, où statistiquement c'est le mois où il y a le moins de personnes actives sur YouTube.
Pour terminer mes vacances et pour éviter de cramer des sujets intéressants qu'on pourrait faire en prenant mieux le temps à la rentrée,
j'organise un jeu de l'été: Le jeu des énigmes !
Tous les jours pendant presque un mois, puisque j'arrêterai avant fin aout quand même,
je vous donne une énigme à résoudre et le lendemain je vous donne la solution de l'énigme avec une nouvelle énigme.
J'espère que cette idée vous plaira. J'ai déjà tourné les vidéos, je les ai tournées à mon deuxième tournage au YouTube Space.
Elles sont montées, elles sont planifiées en ligne, tout est automatisé, vous aurez toujours votre vidéo tous les jours.
Moi pendant ce temps là, je lirai toujours vos commentaires. Je serai moins présent sur la chaine parce que déjà
les 15 premiers jours je serai vraiment parti en vacances. Je ne pense même pas avoir de connexion Internet
je vais me faire un black out, ça va faire du bien.
Et durant les quelques jours qui resterons je serais rentré à Paris, là je redeviendrai plus actif,
je continue toujours de lire les commentaires, j'y répondrai un petit peu.
Et surtout je bosserai pour vous faire un retour encore plus gros, avec une chaine encore plus belle, j'espère.
Et qu'on se fasse une belle dernière ligne droite jusqu'au 31 décembre.
Il y a déjà des choses qui sont en train de se préparer mais je veux bien les préparer, les faire bien.
Dont une vidéo avec Poisson Fécond, j'en suis tellement heureux !
Qui va venir sur la chaine.
Une autre avec Max Bird, et d'autres que je ne vais pas encore vous dire, parce que c'est pas sûr à 100%, c'est pas planifié.
Mais il y a du taf.
Le jeu de l'été, le jeu des énigmes fonctionnera aussi comme ça, grâce à vous.
J'espère que ce sera un rendez-vous qui vous plaira, j'espère que vous partagerez les énigmes un peu partout.
En tout cas je vous ai à l'œil parce que je sais que tous les jours j'irai lire vos commentaires, je trouverai toujours une solution,
une petite connexion durant une heure, au moins pour ça.
Passez de très très belles vacances ! Vous pouvez me souhaiter bonnes vacances avec un geste simple, en laissant un pouce en l'air.
Merci d'être là depuis le départ, j'espère que tout ça, ça vous plait et que ça continuera de vous plaire.
On se retrouve dans du vrai quotidien fin aout. Mais restez là puisque la prochaine vidéo c'est demain.
Alors rendez-vous demain à 17H.
Ciao !